- J'imagine que le Round-up
concentré, d'après ce que vous
me dites, ce ne sera plus légal.
- Rocco Isgro pourra maintenant
suivre sa conscience.
L'interdiction de 36 pesticides
lui permettra de retirer
des tablettes ces produits
qu'il n'ose même pas utiliser.
ROCCO ISGRO, responsable des
ventes, Pépinière Pierrefonds
- Ça va être remplacé
par des choses biologiques.
Est-ce que ça va être aussi
efficace, probablement pas.
Mais est-ce que ça va être mieux
pour l'environnement?
100% mieux. Ça va être une
nuisance, mais je suis certain
que les compagnies sortir
quelque chose de biologique,
ça a déjà commencé,
pour remplacer ça.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Parmi les produits qui vont
disparaître de la métropole :
le glyphosate.
- En vertu du principe de
précaution, Valérie Plante
abolira l'usage et la vente
de 109 produits à base de
pesticides, dont des
néonicotinoïdes mortels
pour les abeilles.
Le règlement devrait
être adopté en septembre
et effectif dès janvier 2022.
- Montréal est la première ville
au Canada, au Québec, évidemment
que l'on souhaite que d'autres
villes emboîtent le pas.
- Une mesure sans précédents
qui touchera également
les exterminateurs, alors que
terrains de golf et corridors
d'Hydro-Québec seront exemptés.
Mais les agriculteurs,
relativement rares à Montréal,
ne feront pas exception.
MARCEL GROLEAU, président gén.,
Union des producteurs agricoles
- Ce qui dérange, c'est qu'on ne
veut pas se ramasser au Québec
avec 1000 règlementations
différentes concernant
l'usage des pesticides.
On demande au gouvernement du
Québec actuellement de s'assurer
que la législation québécoise
pour le secteur agricole
et l'agriculture s'applique
de façon uniforme
à travers le Québec.
- Craignant l'effet boule
de neige, l'UPA demande
l'intervention de Québec.
- L'objectif, c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse accélérer la
transition vers une agriculture
qui est de plus en plus
écologique.
- Mais le ministre de
l'Agriculture a plutôt
évité de prendre position.
ANDRÉ LAMONTAGNE, min. Agricul.,
Pêcheries et Alimentation
- Je suis tout à fait confiant
que tout le monde qui sont en
lien avec l'agriculture,
puis le bioalimentaire au Québec
vont trouver une façon